hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of thrones if you like to watch
the full episode head over to
youtube.com slash GameSpot please beware
of spoilers so again I thought this
episode had a lot of setup we I mean the
last three episodes they're also gonna
be longer which I'm really excited about
because they have so much to get through
um
there's lots of things that we've been
waiting seasons for yeah coming to a
head so I think I is a great place to
start with this because I think this is
the end of her Braavos her Braavos story
arc I guess Dave you've got some great
theories about this
so obviously mentioned before what
happens a ire was that she was bold
Sprouse going through the market got
stabbed escaped and kind of don't know
what's gonna happen to her now there are
a couple of theories about what went on
here because it felt very unnatural for
I um a few people are thinking that it
could be jaqen pretending to be aya to
test the waif I like that a lot yeah
it's I mean it it'd have to you'd have
to shrink down right like well no I mean
that's the thing about the faceless men
is that they kind of have that weird
ability yeah cuz are you her face was
used on a dead body before right when
she just before she went blind well the
piece of music the play during the scene
is called Valar morghulis
so that's hinting the connection to the
faceless men and we also know that jaqen
may have something of a soft spot for
aya he like took her in he helped her
out killing Lannisters and took her in
when she finally came over to Braavos
and he tells the wave don't let her
suffer
now I'm gonna stab you multiple times in
this won't make in that scene she could
have had the perfect opportunity to just
cut her throat you end it but instead I
think he's banking on the fact that the
waif really dislikes her and goes for
the slash and in the stomach and the
place where you want the place you stab
someone if you want to suffer is the
stomach it can take days to bleed out
from a stomach wound or a stomach
gunshot as we see in Reservoir Dogs to
get a reference in there um so it could
be jacking like testing the waif seeing
if the waif is kind of harboring a
grudge which obviously she's not
supposed to exactly
but another theory which I think may
hold more water is that area knew
exactly what she was doing
she fully expected to be attacked by the
wave yeah her mannerisms are they seen a
much different to how she normally acts
she's very cocky flashing a cash to draw
her attention to herself is she holding
needle as well she's going no she is
she's unarmed yeah she is like this
though yeah and and I have a theory as
to that stance yeah I've got in deep
here so she's drawing attention to
herself throwing all this money around
people in this area obviously going to
be drawn to you know cash be a lot of
money out um so I think that's exactly
what she wants she does she doesn't have
to escape this way she doesn't have to
pay a man to take her away she could
she's got the ninja ability used to
sneak on a ship at night stow away and
get away yeah when the wave approaches
wearing the face of an old woman I was
hanging out on the bridge yeah
this location is chosen by aya in
advance because it has an escape route
yeah she could jump off the bridge and
that's her out mm-hmm stabbing like okay
people might say well she got stabbed I
think she knew she was gonna get stamped
yeah I think she might have been banking
on the wave being we see her get stabbed
we see a bleed but who's she recently
taken a shine to late-late brain and who
would you go to see if you wanted to act
wounded it would not surprise me if the
actors knew how to fake a wound for
their plays maybe it's like a pig's
bladder full of fake blood and that's
what she's using tonight
kind of disguise and make the way think
she's wounded so she's blood bloody
stabbed way think she's wounded her she
falls into the water but the waste got
to confirm the kill right yeah when cut
leave you can't you can't you know you
got to pick up the doctor exactly can't
get your contract banged and the when
aya escapes from the water she's leaving
a trail of blood hmm and when we see in
the last episode at the end of it she's
got needle she's in a dark area and
she's kind of waiting so I think I has
led a trail to that dark area where the
wife is going to expect a wounded
unarmed aya instead really
it's aya who's armed with needle who no
one else knows about she is completely
fine and she has the training to fight
with
site she's in Matt Murdock mode wife is
gone get ruined but also like whenever
she's trained with way if it's always
been with the staff right yeah how's the
waif ever shown any proficiency in sword
fighting because we know that I had a
training with yeah sort of Bravo Syrio
Forel someone also did the the freeze
frames of the old woman's face yeah and
have gone back a little while and I
actually sees the face the way fuses in
the Hall of faces so she would
immediately see this face and be like
I've seen that before anyway really so
mean do you think that I is really in
trouble or is this just her master ninja
plan finally come it definitely feels
like it's a ninja plan because it's just
it's contrary to everything she's
learned so far contrary to the way she
behaves as a character yeah you know
running into a trap that kind of thing
it's it seems too reckless to be aya
yeah I'm so there's something
interesting happening and I really like
the idea of seeing her kind of combine
hurt
Syrio Forel training with her faceless
men training using needle cuz she's but
she's always been using the kind of
stuff
she's known and good yeah and she's been
okay I mean she's there were points
where she was taking the wave down and
this is why she was blind so imagine
what she can do when she can see or even
is blinded and has needle which is a
weapon suited to her she's a little more
life she's a little more like balletic
with that stuff she is gonna wreak some
Falls with her song and it's gonna be
awesome we don't even know if the wave
had the whole blind thing because that
was implied is it was a punishment for
aya for rip like that she took down
Meryn Trant yeah and the PO punishment
was to lose her sight yeah so the wave
may never have had that so she's going
in she's actually going in blind Maya is
completely fine I'm gonna murder her
some waif outright
you